die sogenannten aktivisten die auf der
straße wie so oft in der hauptstadt
eigentlich mittlerweile fast jeden tag
die chaoten von die letzte generation
nennen sie sich die blockieren hier die
frankfurter li hier mit der in berlin
sie sehen führt natürlich zu einem
langen langen stau die polizei dort im
einsatz richtig mühsam dort die
angeklebten chaoten dann wieder von der
fahrbahn zu kriegen mit öl und allen
dann werden sie weggebracht jeden tag
eine neue aktion ja gibt's nicht
ausgerechnet an dem tag also wirklich
zeitgleich mit dem momentan weg der uns
allen auch so schwieriger art und weise
ja uns auf schwierige zeiten ein schwert
kleben die sich noch fest dort auf der
straße da sollte man klare worte von der
politik erwarten klar sich zu
distanzieren vor allen dingen dieses
problem der menschen die sich da immer
wieder an die straße kleben endlich mal
in griff kriege aber das gegenteil
passiert hier in berlin schauen sie was
die grüne bezirksbürgermeisterin von
friedrichshain-kreuzberg da wo die leute
auf der straße kleben auch dort gesagt
hat
und finden heute passiert
um zu zeigen das ist eine solidarität
wird und dass wir gemeinsam anpacken
eine solidarität gibt es aber nicht etwa
mit der polizei man sieht den
einsatzwagen dahinter ihr die dort im
einsatz sind und helfen dass der verkehr
dort mit rascher wieder läuft die dabei
helfen irgendwie die menschen von der
straße zu entfernen die hände das ist
einzigartig solidarität mit denen die
auf diese art und weise für klima
kämpfen klar eine gute sache auf diese
art und weise jedoch sie distanziert
sich in dem moment von den eigenen
regeln von der eigenen polizei ein stück
weit vom eigenen staat die grüne
bezirksbürgermeisterin und um das noch
mal klar zu machen die das sind
diejenigen die am gestrigen tag auch das
kanzleramt beschmiert haben mit
schwarzer farbe wir können diese bilder
nochmal zeigen da haben sie eben auch
protestiert in ihren orangen westen über
all diese diesem schwarzen mister hin
geschmiert und eben auch an die wende
vom kanzleramt also das sind die mit
denen sich die grüne
bezirksbürgermeisterin hier sehen sie
die wand von olaf scholz arbeitsstätte
dort kanzleramt das sind die mit denen
sich die grüne bezirksbürgermeisterin
hier von friedrichshain kreuzberg in
berlin
solidarisiert